many Gen Xers now 35 to 50 years old are  feeling a financial pinch Gen Xers are  what economists call a sandwich class  squeezed between raising their kids and  caring for aging parents 40 percent have  children under 18 and about 1/4 have a  parent or another relative living in  their households that's significantly  more than the general population many  Gen Xers are struggling to pay student  loans 38% say they have more debt than  savings more than any other generation  almost 40% say they don't feel at all  financially secure and they are saving  less for retirement on average people in  their 40s have saved 62 thousand dollars  in 401k plans at the end of 2013  that means Gen Xers who plan to retire  at 65 have a ways to go to accumulate  the 1 million dollars they'll need to  generate $40,000 a year as seniors Xers  could be the first generation of  Americans that won't do as well as their  parents  you